now a lot of you know that i am an
accomplished songwriter song parody
writer i have done things like um beers
in heaven classic or total eclipse of
the fart um i love i like them to sing
them but i am not going to be
doing that today i am going to be doing
something i wrote specifically for toby
do you know um
goodbye stranger super [ __ ] yeah
it was early morning yesterday
i was up before the dawn
[Music]
and i really have enjoyed my stay
toby must be moving on
[Music]
i'm gonna miss toby
he has a nice calming presence in the
office
[Music]
don't tell him i said this but i always
thought it was kind of cute
[Music]
goodbye tommy
next on the list song parodies
okay okay ak breaking fart great let's
sing it in the car no no no no my stumps
like my humps but guy with no legs yeah
we can do this
we can do this
a little bit of pam all night long a
little bit of angela on the thing
a little
[Music]
hey send me that link to the monkey sex
video
i'm going to forward it like it's hot
yes
board it like it's hot fold it like it's
hot then old school
sitting in my office with a plate of
grilled vegan call my man black just to
see what was shaking yo mike our town is
dope and pretty so check out how we live
in the electric city
they call it scranton what the electric
city script what the electric city lazy
scranton the electric city they call it
that cause of the electricity the city's
laid out from east to west and our
public parks and libraries are truly the
best call poison control if you're bit
by a spider but check that it's covered
by your health care provider plenty of
space in the parking lot but the little
cars go win the compact spot spot spot
spot watch [ __ ]
snack attack time don't lose your hair
we like who genus for the tasty bread
they call it grant what the electric
city britain what the electric city
sprint what the electric city scrape
want the electric city sprint
one
[Music]
[Music]
the dundies are kind of like a kid's
birthday party
and you go
and there's really nothing for you to do
there
but the kids having a really good time
so yeah you're kind of there
that's that's kind of what it's like
the waitress tripped on the cord all
right
all right joke landed ah i
did you ask me here for any specific
reason uh yes i did
i got it i got it
[Music]
let's get ethical ethical
i want to get ethical
let's get into ethics yeah let me hear
the dynamically talk
your body talk let me hear your body
talk
whoa all right all right i'm ready to go
and i'll call a shotgun
i'm done
yes thank you
all right let me just say goodbye to pam
oh yeah you better you better say
goodbye to pam
say goodbye to pam
bye
[Music]
inside jim's car i don't know when i'll
be back again yes i do
tomorrow i'll be back
i'll be back tomorrow
bye
bye
miss chair model
lady a [ __ ] that we were married and
you treated me nice
we had lots of kids
drinking whiskey and rye
but why'd you have to go off and die
why'd you have to go off and die
oh
you believe in rock and roll can music
save your mortal soul
and man
[Music]
real slow
well
[Music]
[Music]
this is going out to indians everywhere
it's a tribute to one of the greats mr
adam sandler
dualies a festival of lights
let me tell you something tonight has
been
one crazy
night
[Music]
so pour
on your sorries it's time to celebrate
to ollie
everybody looks so jolly
but it's not christmas it's diwali
the goddess of destruction kali stopped
by to celebrate a wally
don't invite any zombies to a
celebration of diwali
a long game party to have some fun as a
wally
if you're in the union you love to party
have a happy happy
[Music]
[Applause]
you